[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
el mediterráneo es la ruta más peligrosa
para los migrantes que buscan llegar a
europa cada verano aumenta
considerablemente el tránsito y también
las personas a la deriva en
embarcaciones peligrosas y en el éxodo
las ong cumplen un papel importante ante
la inacción de los gobiernos los
bloqueos en el mar y la negativa para el
desembarco en puerto seguro agudizan la
situación de los que buscan mejores
condiciones de vida
a lo lejos un bote inflable más de 100
migrantes viajaban en él hasta que
fueron rescatados por activistas de
médicos sin fronteras ubicados en el río
bárents
un barco ambulancia que navega por el
mediterráneo central en busca de
inmigrantes a la deriva mientras viajan
a la espera de un puerto seguro médico
se examinan sus heridas méndez y según
vemos comúnmente heridas de arma blanca
medidas de bala incluso quemaduras
encontramos evidencias de electrocución
muchos golpes con las mangueras cosas
así entonces
cicatrices que quedan como consecuencia
de un tormentoso viaje desde sus países
de origen hasta la costa norteafricana
con libia como un país de tránsito pero
más de bloqueo en su camino hacia europa
en libia
en libia hay mucha violencia
capturan a la gente de sus campamentos
principales los llevan a prisión e
intentan pedirles dinero así que es
difícil
entre en libia y atraparon los
traficantes los traficantes me golpearon
usaron electricidad miren mi cara mis
manos
según sobrevivientes el 84% de los actos
violentos reportados tuvieran lugar en
libia y un gran número se dio después de
ser interceptados por guardacostas
el 29 por ciento de las víctimas fueron
menores de edad y 18% mujeres en un año
de operaciones el equipo de bárents
rescató a unas tres mil 138 personas en
el mar y atendió seis mil 536 consultas
médicas a bordo
la realidad de lo que pasa en altamar va
más allá de las cifras que deja la
migración por el mediterráneo para
hablar de la situación en la frontera
sur de europa contactamos previamente a
hernán gauna oficial de comunicación
para el proyecto de búsqueda y rescate
en el mediterráneo de médicos sin
fronteras ellos denuncian una
normalización de las políticas de
disuasión y del desmantelamiento del
sistema de búsqueda
bueno básicamente lo que sucedió es que
hace varios años que la unión europea
desistió de
completar sus obligaciones con respecto
a la búsqueda rescate en el mar que está
dictada por el derecho internacional y
el derecho marítimo en otras palabras
los estados miembros deberían estar
teniendo sus programas de búsqueda y
rescate y coordinando las operaciones
búsqueda y rescate en sus respectivas
zonas pero en su lugar decidió ir por
otro camino que es desmantelar estos
sistemas es decir no existe no hay
proactivamente flotas que realicen
tareas de rescate y delegar lo de algún
modo tercerizarlo en un estado como
libia el cual recibe financiamiento de
la unión europea
para
reforzar las tareas de diríamos del
patrullaje en la zona fronteriza a libia
y el objetivo principal de esto es que
las personas sean interceptadas y
devueltas a libia en lugar de
propiamente rescatadas el problema es
que libia no es un país seguro y por eso
estas personas están intentando escapar
y esta situación
ha venido como sosteniéndose en el
tiempo y realmente no hay respuestas
alternativas de hecho la unión europea
ratificó que va a seguir invirtiendo en
este programa y en esta manera de
hacerlo
en la ruta más peligrosa para los
migrantes los desafíos para las ong
también son múltiples y van desde
cuestiones de seguridad en el tránsito
hasta obstáculos burocráticos hernán
gauna se refirió a algunos de ellos ha
habido una persecución e incluso
criminalización de las tareas de
búsqueda y rescate por parte de países
de la unión europea en particular en
italia
y además eso por un lado
y por otro lado
dentro de esta
normalización de esta situación lo que
lo que vemos es que se ha acentuado o
tiende a ver como una acentuación de de
la las esperas las demoras a las que se
someten a los a los barcos que realiza
esas tareas
entonces lo que sucede es que cuando el
barco solicita un lugar seguro para
desembarcar no recibe la respuesta
adecuada genera demoras innecesarias e
incluso ha habido como situaciones de
cuarentena saro literarias o digamos
todo tipo de
artilugios para demorar el trabajo
en el mar así y por otro lado como
tercer riesgo si éste
como llamarles empoderamiento de la
guardia costera libia también hemos
visto situaciones de intimidación
digamos vamos a llamarle sutil pero las
biblias organizaciones las han vivido
con respecto a buena hora de costera que
quizá realiza maniobras o habido
situaciones en la cuerda un disparo al
aire que obviamente deja las
organizaciones digamos un poco a solas
para un poco no totalmente a solas e
cubriendo un
un vacío ahí en el que los estados no
están están tomando las cartas que
deberían
entre 2017 y 2021 al menos 8.500
personas murieron o desaparecieron en la
ruta por el mediterráneo' 95 mil fueron
retornadas a libia y el año pasado
registró el número más alto de
devoluciones forzosas hasta la fecha
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]